ايه الحاجه تزوج جدل على قانون محتمل
للاسره في مصر
ويسرى تعلنها صراحه اكره السوشال ميديا
وعمرو مصطفى الضيف 25 سؤال اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
رح نبدا حلقه تفاعلكم هذا اليوم مشاهدينا
من مصر فحاله من الجدل الواسع عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي تشرق بمصر وسبب منشورات
بتدعي الشباب المصري للزواج وبسرعه القصه
وما فيها انه صار في تداوله منشورات تابعه
لمئذون ماذون انكحايه الشباب للزواج قبل
صدور قانون احوال الاسره الجديده الماذون
طالب الشباب بالزواج بشكل عاجل حتى لا
يدفعوا 30,000 جنيه لصندوق دعم الاسره الا
انه الايثار ما كان حدا يتوقعوا عموما
وازاله العدل ما سكته تبعت المنشورات
وتوصلت انه بعض هذه المنشورات تابعه
للماذون الشرعي محمد درويش مصطفى اولى
مساعد ياسر القرشي اللي كان يكتب بعض
المنشورات وينشر صور اقدام الماذون على
توثيق عقود زواج الموضوع اكيد ما صحن في
وزاره العدل حاله واقعه الماذون للنيابه
العامه لتولي التحقيق والتهمه نشر رسائل
غير حقيقيه بتحمل شائعات مغرضه عابر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي يا جماعه المصريين ما
صدقوها كلمه من وقت ما طلع القرار انتشرت
منشورات وتغريدات سخريه وتهكم بشكل كبير
خلونا نشوف بعضها
ما حدا فينا بقدر ينكر قديش مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اخذ جزء كبير من حياتنا ولم
نكون واقعين اكثر كثار فينا بيجي وقت
وبياخذوا فرصه
وبيبتعدوا عنها يعني اجازه نوع من انواع
الاجازه بس هل يا ترى بنقدر نستغني عنها
استغناء تام بصراحه ما بعتقد لانه شو قصه
او لكن قصه الفنانه يسرا
ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي شكلها قصه كبيره
لانه يسرا وخلال تواجدها بلقاء تلفزيوني
شنت هجوم اقل ما يقال عنه انه حاد على
موقع التواصل الاجتماعي ورواتها خلونا
نسمع سؤالك
جوجل
اذا مثل ما شفتوا يا جماعه يسرى ومنتهى
الحده اللي بتخالف اسلوبها اللي احنا
متعودين عليه عبرت عن كرها واشتياقها من
مستخدمين السوشيال ميديا قالت انه بعض
المستخدمين هدفهم انهم يشيطين وافعال
الفنانين والمشهورين ويبينوا حالهم انه هم
الناس اللي مناح ونقطه ثانيه كثير مهمه
حكت عنها يسرى كمان هي انه الجمهور صار عم
يقتحم حياه الفنانين لدرجه خليتها في بعض
المرات تختفي علشان ما يعرفوها وقالت انه
هي مضطره تتحمل وبصراحه ليكون واقعيين
شويه يعني الموضوع بصير في بعض الاحيان
كثير وهذا شيء ما بنقدر ينكره
ايهاب فين كافيه
عام 2022 ما خلى ولا اقتصاد
كبيره في العالم لدرجه يا جماعه انه صار
الاكل والملابس عم يشكلوا تحدي لا كثير من
الناس اليوم الدراسه الي عم نحكي عنها
اجرتها الشركه الاستشارات كيف يعني
3000 شخص بيب بريطانيا
اكثر من هيك كمان الدراسه البريطانيه وجدت
انه نصف المشمولين بالاستطلاع هما بيسعوا
عم حاليا يسحبوا مدخراتهم لمساعدتهم على
تلبيه التكاليف الاساسيه بس
ايران ما كفاها تعدم وتعتقل وتعذب
المحتاجين لا كمان اليوم صارت تصدر قرارات
من خلالها من بعض اللاعبات الايرانيات
فبعد بعد ما شاركت في دوره دوليه من دون
حجاب رئيس الاتحاد الشطرنج الايراني اعلن
انه اللاعيبه ساره خادم لم تكن تمثل بلاده
وعلق على ظهور اللاعب وقال بانه صار خادم
شاركت بحريه وعلى نفقتها الخاصه وفقه
زعموا طبعا اكيد الاعلان يا جماعه اذا بعد
ما شاركت لاعبه الشطرنج الايرانيه في دوله
دوليه من دون ارتداء الحجاب لتكون الاحدث
من بين رياضيات ايرانيات
ظهرنا في منافسات من دون ارتداء الحجاب
منذ بدا الاحتجاجات المناهضه للحكومه
صحيفه خبر وزرشي واعتماد قالوا انه لاعبنا
فساد في بطوله هذه الشطرنج اتبعتين
للاتحاد الدولي للشطرنج في كازاخستان من
دون ارتداح حجاب ونشروا كمان صور بتظهر
اللاعبه من دون الحجاب في هذه الدوره
بالوقت اللي ما نشرت ساره خادم اي تعليق
لا على الدوره او على التقارير
الم فيكم من جديد مشاهدينا طبعا ختام
حلقات تفاعلكم بهذا الاسبوع وهذه السنه
كمان راح تكون بفقره 25 سؤال وضيفها
الفنانه المصريه عمرو مصطفى طبعا مع
الزميله ساره الدندراوي انا باقول لكم كل
عام وانتم بخير والى اللقاء
عمرو مصطفى 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم
بسرعه ومن غير تفكير اغنيه صنعت اسمك
من هو نجم مصر الاول اليوم
محمد منير
[موسيقى]
خالص
ما اقدرش مثلا مزاجك النهارده
لو بشره خير زي خليك فاكرني زي العالم
والله
زي دائره
يبقى هو لازم يراجع دكتور نفسي عشان يعرف
ان ده مش شبه ده
نوال صحيح
دلوقت
متاخر انا غلطان
غريبه الدنيا
[موسيقى]
حاضر طيب معروف عنك كثره الخلافات ولكن
رجعت وقلت انك فتحت صفحه جديده وخلاص طيب
لكن برضو استمريت في التصريحات اللي بتزعل
الناس منك يعني طلعت في برنامج ورجع حتى
كذا مطرب كتبه بوستات وردوا عليكم ملحن
كتبوست ورد عليك وحتى انت حطيت بوست قلت
انه انت جالس تتفرج على ردود افعالهم يعني
استمريت شويه صراحه
ما فيش مشاكل اللي حصل اللي بتقول ده
الاحداث دي حصلت قبل ما انزل اليها دائره
مش بعدين بعد ما نزلت اول اغنيه ليا اللي
هي من ثلاث شهور اغنيه اللي انا انا جبت
سيره احد خالص وما حدش قرب مني يعني
وما نزلوش اغاني من ساعتها والله من اول
ما انا نزلت ما حدش نزل اغاني حبيبي قاعد
طب اعمل ايه طيب تمام
الناس كلها عايشه في عالم واحد على فكره
والعالم بقى صغير يعني السوشيال ميديا
خلاص انستغرام
لا خوف من الموسيقى
اوكي همم فممكن كل الشعب دلوقتي العربي
يعرف ازاي المضروب من الاصل طيب تحب تسمي
احد بتحديدا كمان يروحوا يلاحظوا صفحته
اكثر
ثابت اليوتيوب لانها خافت لانها ما بتجيبش
حتى مليون فخاف قال لك لا انا هاروح حته
ثانيه لا احنا اليوتيوب ده مش هننزل فيها
اغاني ثاني لا كثير انا ممكن الناس تبحث
تعمل سيرش على جوجل من اللي مانع اغاني من
اليوتيوب
مع الرجال
الرجال افضل من الستات الستات متفوقه على
الرجال في حاجات كثيره جدا
خلاص الناس كلها انت صح
اسمع الناس بتقول انك غيران من نجاح
مطربين مهرجانات علشان هم صاروا نجوم
اليوم
اوكي الاستماره تقطع صح اوكي اذا قلت لك
لازم تختار وحده منهم عمل مصطفى مطرب او
ملحن ايش تختار
اوكي لو سالنا زوجتك عن ابرز عيب فيك
تتوقع ايش هيكون رده فعلها او ردها
تمثال
والله يعني مراتي دي لازم تعمليها تمثال
كبير يعني تمثال في اماكن كثيره لان ما
فيش حد هيستحمل ال ال ال المود المتغير ده
غير الانسان العظيم
عايز اقول لك الحمد لله عمري ما حسيت به
لان انا راجل ببقى خايف شويه قبل ما انزل
اي حاجه وبابقى وسواس جدا فاكيد اما بنزل
حاجه بكون
يعني ربنا موفقني فيها لان ببقى
متردد قبل ما انزل بكثير يعني بختار
اختيارات دقيقه يعني انا ممكن يعني انا
دائما كان فيه يعني
بحترم نفسك
اوكي يعني زي الناس الان عايزه يقعدوا في
البيت مع نجاح حضرتك
مش يعني هتقول لك ده مغرور
الفنانه والفنانه اللي بحب احضن لهم حفله
منير بحب احضر حفلاته لانه مختلف
اعوذ بالله من كلمه انا واعوذ بالله من
الغرور
يرتقي بنفسه البشريه ويحس ان هو ان هو 20
لو حياتك اغنيه ايش هتكون
اليوم تصغر
منك
ههه 20 يعني انا كنت بعمل لمستك ساعتها ما
كنتش هلحها لحد ثاني خلاص كنت هكمل في
الغور دي نصيحه اللي كنت مفروض اديها
لنفسك
تغني لي مقطع منه
وانت اللي بحلم اعيش معاك
والليله هي البداء يعني انا عايز بس
المطربين يغنوها انا عايز المطربين يغنوها
هيسمعوني صوتهم فيها ده واحد غير بارتاح
معك
اه يا رب يا حبيبي لما نرجع للسؤال واحد
العار جدا ههه
الان لازم نرجع له طيب كل الاغاني اللي
اصدرها عمرو مصطفى في 20 22 سيبوا الا انا
يا دائره وغيرهم كلها اغاني عنه وبيوجه
فيها رسائل لناس معينه صح او غلط
الشهر اللي بيكون دائما اصحابي او اصدقائي
او في الفتره اللي انا بلحن فيها بيكونوا
عايشين حاله معينه يعني هي اغنيه يا دائره
دي دي حالتي من سنتين ههه
بس انا نزلتها دلوقت لان انا وعدت الناس
ان انا هانزل كل الاغاني القديمه اللي
عندي على الموبايل ودي عددهم
1780,780 اغنيه نزلت منهم اثنين سيبووه
همم طيب لحن الكل قال لك عليه لا واصريت
انك تنزله ونزل اكسر الدنيا
[موسيقى]
يعني يعني الحمد لله بص هقول لك شويه حاجه
طالعه انا بلحن كثير قوي قوي ده لحم في
اليوم مثلا كثير
20 اغنيه انا ما بتعجبنيش وجمله واحده
صغيره قد كده تعجبني واقعد بس ست شهور ما
تعجبنيش غير الجمله دي هي دي اللي بتنزل
للناس انا عندي اغاني كثيره جدا فمش دائما
همم باحساس ده بس في لحن ممكن تكون انت
عج- عجبك بس في ناس حواليك قالوا لك لا مش
حلوه بس بعدين نجح
همم
يمكن بيطلع كل حاجه من قلبي قوي فببقى
حاسسها قوي ما حستش الاحساس
انا ما باخذش رايك حد انا ببص في وشه اوكي
طيب اختار اغنيه واهديها لشخص
معينه
ممكن مثلا
انا كل حاجه تغيرت فيا بهواك دي مرات يعني
دي مش شخص دي دي الروح
غلاف السنه انا عندي الخلاف حرفانه
شكرا
[موسيقى]